[Música]
eu acredito que muita gente aqui conhece
o slogan do ted é ideias que merecem ser
divulgadas mas um fator importante é a
gente tem que pensar que essas idéias
precisam ser entendidas por quem é
compor essas pessoas com quem ela estão
sendo divulgadas hoje em dia no mundo
existem mais de sete milhões de pessoas
dessas sete bilhões de pessoas somente
13% fala inglês como as palestras do ted
em sua maioria são são faladas inglesa e
para cada uma pessoa no mundo que fala
inglês
existem sete outras que não falam inglês
ou seja está privando essas sete pessoas
entenderem essa ideia de serem
inspiradas por essas idéias
somente porque elas não entendem o
idioma da silva falava e quando a gente
fala de de português como essas coisas
todas que a gente tem visto aqui hoje a
situação é ainda pior para cada pessoa
que fala português existem 28 outras
pessoas que não falam português não
mudam pra tentar minimizar um pouco esse
problema foi que surgiu o projeto do ted
translators otegi translatores é um
grupo de pessoas no mundo inteiro
um grupo de voluntários que dedica um
pouco do seu próprio tempo para traduzir
essas palestras que tanto inspiram nos
seus idiomas locais
o projeto começou em 2009 a partir da
iniciativa de dessas pessoas que queriam
trazer as palestras testes mas as
famosas mais conhecidas para suas
comunidades locais começou somente 300
traduções e em 40 idiomas diferentes em
depois de alguns anos quando já tinha
começado ele passou a incluir também
palestras ted x e ted
nesse ponto o projeto passou a servir
como uma via dupla em vez de somente
levar as idéias em inglês para o resto
do mundo também passou a trazer todas as
idéias do ted x que eram faladas em
jogos diferentes de inglês para o mundo
que fala inglês também hoje em dia em
a gente tem o projeto já traduz em mais
de 100 idiomas diferentes conta com a
colaboração de 25 mil
voluntários em 155 países do mundo e mês
passado a gente ultrapassou a marca de
100.000 traduções publicadas
falando um pouco mais especificamente do
brasil no brasil a gente tem mais de 900
voluntários ajudando a trazer as
palestras e contamos com mais de 4500
traduções publicadas isso coloca gente
como a segunda maior comunidade de
idioma dentro do do projeto e
ultimamente o grupo de tradutores o
projeto de tradução vem trabalhando
junto com vários eventos testes para
tentar estreitar um pouco as relações
entre os produtores e os x
ele também tentará promover a a
interação entre os produtores entre si
mesmo são alguns eventos que acontecerão
em alguns encontros que acontecerão
eventos em são paulo o papel do tradutor
é muito importante pro teste x é pra
ajudar na divulgação de palestras é
difícil também porque o ted próprio abre
espaço na sua página oficial para a
divulgação de palestras que não faladas
em inglês mas antes disso as peças têm
que ser transcritas e traduzidas para o
inglês então é aí que entra o tradutor
também e importante também dizer que
todos esses voluntários eles não eles
nem sempre tem um background de tradução
o didget legislação nem todo mundo tem
experiência prévia então não é
necessário conhecer nada sua tradução ou
legenda ação para fazer parte desse
grupo
então qualquer pessoa que quiser
participar é só entrar no site do ted e
clicar em participe
além disso muita gente não fala inglês
então isso não exclui que você também
ajude que como eu falei antes todas as
palestras precisam ser antes de traduzir
nossas ser transcrita segunda voluntário
precisa escrever o que o palestrante
está dizendo no idioma original e pra
isso basta falar português já palestras
está sendo dado em português
eu pessoalmente faço parte do projeto
mais de 4 a um pouco mais de quatro anos
o coordenador há pouco mais de três anos
e eu posso dizer que é uma experiência
fantástica vale muito a pena porque além
de saber que você está ajudando uma
causa boa você em contato com todas
essas idéias inspiradoras e também ti
proporciona conhecer pessoas incríveis
são os produtores vão
obrigado
[Aplausos]